Bob Kravitz of wthr.com and Indianapolis
after spending 15 years with the
Indianapolis Star calling into the rich
Oz and show how you doing Bob how are
you I'm fine what can you tell us about
this when when when did the tampering
charges get filed best you can tell from
the Pacers well shortly after they got
the phone call from Aaron Mintz the way
it started they heard a lot of rumors
that there had been some correspondence
between the Lakers executives and Paul
George's people and they're already
becoming concerned then I know that
Kevin Prichard the GM and herb Simon
were among the Pacers executives who
actually saw the Jimmy Kimmel interview
with magic and they were very angry they
were beside themselves and they thought
something rotten is going on here then
yeah
move ahead about a month and a half two
months later they get the phone call
from George's representative saying
we're leaving in 2018 and we want to go
to the Lakers and it was shortly
thereafter I believe it was June that
the Pacers said you know what this is
something we need to do and from what I
hear a lot of the small and mid market
executives around the league are telling
the Pacers go for it because they're
going to be there in the same situation
where they're going to lose their
superstars from small markets to the to
the marquee markets so the question is
though is did it really impact their
ability to trade him or solutely but the
magic Johnson Jimmy Kimmel appearance
well now what effect that it was the
fact that minced the agent you know
whoever whoever gave it to Adrienne was
jurasky what what did what it did was it
put the Pacers in the situation where I
told the entire league that he wanted to
end up with the Lakers so it limited
their their trade market which was not
robust as you could tell from what they
got for them it limited the trade mark
get two teams that were looking for a
one-year rental and it also told the
Lakers you know what you don't need to
go out and offer the Pacers anything
because you're going to get them for
free after the 2017-2018 season so it
destroyed the market and made it very
difficult for the Colts to get much more
than pennies on the dollar for Paul
George wthr.com columnist Bob Kravitz
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show a
couple more questions for you on this
would you would you say that Pacers
turned down better offers up for the
mere fact that the better offers were
coming from teams in their conference
and they didn't want to send Paul George
their follow absolutely not because you
know they've got to think about their
long-term future they want to get the
best offer regardless of where it comes
from understanding that in 2018 he's
going to end probably going to end up
with the Lakers out in the Western
Conference so you know let's say
Cleveland made a great offer it would be
it would be ridiculous for them to say
no we don't want this great offer
because he's going to spend one year in
our division in our conference that
makes no sense
so no they know he's going to end up in
LA somehow unless his tampering charge
is proven and then one of the one of the
penalties possibly is that they can
restrict the Lakers from ever signing
Paul George haha so best I can tell Bob
and you tell me if this is an accurate
reading of this magic goes on Jimmy
Kimmel has fun with the wink wink stuff
Pacers see that they get pissed that and
then they're told by the agent hey he
wants out and he's going to go to the
Lakers if you don't trade him which then
becomes public and they think it all
starts with what the Lakers did or
there's something else afoot that they
know about or they're trying to see if
that's a rock they can kick over through
the tampering charge well they said they
feel very strongly that there were
correspondence correspondences between
Lakers Lakers executives and Paul George
is representative they had heard those
rumors for quite some time they think
there's some there there
and that's why you have the outside
counsel who is now going to make sure
they go through all the emails and the
texts and everything else just to see if
there's a if there's anything going on
and last one for you Bob what week do
you think Andrew Luck starts for the
Colts well this would be a complete
guest rich I'm going to guess the second
week I got to think that you know the
reason they didn't go out and get a
Colin Kaepernick or another decent
quarterback I think the Kaepernick
situation has other other levels to it
but I they feel like if he misses done
sometime in the regular season it won't
be a long term proposition so they feel
like they can live with Scott towles in
because you haven't helped us for a game
or two and that they'll get luck back
the problem and what you the problem
that is it how good is luck gonna be we
had the situation here in 2008 with
Peyton Manning where he missed the
entire or most of the of training camp
and he was horrendous through seven
games by Peyton Manning standards and
then oh by the way he won nine in a row
one be MVP so but you know they're going
to get off to I would think that Andrew
if he's a human being and missing as
much time as he has you know having not
engaged in football activities for seven
eight months it's hard to imagine he's
going to come back and be at the top of
his game I appreciate the time thanks
for calling in okay
you got here you got us Bob Kravitz
wthr.com columnist the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our apps don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about